was genau ist am 11 november 2008 10
nahe der französischen insel mayotte im
indischen ozean passiert weltweit wurden
seismischen signale beobachtet alles
deutet auf ein schweres erdbeben
doch niemand habe es registriert oder
gespürt feststeht erfasst wurde eine
seltsame konstante und lange vibration
bei der es sich aber nicht um ein
erdbeben im klassischen sinne anderen
kann alles was ihr bis jetzt zu diesen
unerklärlichen signalen wissen erfahrt
ihr jetzt bei krieg zum science fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
das seismische ereignis das im november
2008 10 die erde erschütterte muss etwa
25 kilometer vor der französischen insel
mayotte im indischen ozean
sein ursprung gehabt haben mayotte liegt
nördlich von madagaskar vor der ostküste
afrikas soweit konnten forschungsteams
die mysteriöse signale nachvollziehen
denn wenige zeit später hatten
seismometer die möglichen erdbebenwellen
in afrika und später dann auch in
neuseeland kanada chile unter bei
registriert also teilweise rund 17.000
kilometer weit entfernt doch das kuriose
an der ganzen sache ist dass diese
erschütterung nirgendwo auf der erde von
irgendeinem menschen bemerkt worden sind
dabei dauerte die wellen ziemlich lange
an nämlich etwa 20 minuten wie die
aufzeichnung der seismographen zeigen
und das ist im vergleich zu einem
klassischen erdbeben wirklich lang wenn
dabei entladen sich aufgestaute spannung
in der erdkruste in einem zeitraum von
wenigen sekunden meist was ist da also
in den tiefen des ozeans passiert
experten und expertinnen rund um die
ganze welt rätseln was es mit diesen
ausschlägen auf sich haben könnte
ein geologe der universität von columbia
gehören extrem sagt dazu in einem
interview mit national geographic ich
glaube nicht dass ich so etwas schon
einmal gesehen haben zu viele faktoren
seien an diesem ereignis einfach äußerst
merkwürdig wie beispielsweise die
ausbreitung der wellen über weite teile
der erde dazu kommt im gegensatz zu
gewöhnlichen erdbeben entstanden keine
und es fehlen damit sind in der
fachsprache wellenmuster gemeint die
eine hohe frequenz aufweisen und am
anfang eines normalen erdbebens
registriert werden p wellen stehen für
primär wählen die sich schneller
ausbreiten und an
einem ort der vom beben herd entfernt
ist für erst aufgezeichnet werden erst
dann folgen die es fehlen also sekundär
wellen ausgelöst werden sie dadurch dass
sie spannungen lösen die sich in der
erdkruste aufgestaut hatten hierbei
verschiebt sich also plötzlich das
gestein und vom erdbeben her breiten
sich nach allen seiten schwingungen des
bodens aus in der fachsprache werden sie
als sogenannte raum wellen bezeichnet
doch wie gesagt konnten sie beim
unerklärten ereignis vom 11 november
2018 nicht beobachtet werden
forschungsteams schlussfolgern daraus
dass sich an diesem tag auf keinen fall
ein stark beben in dieser region
ereignet haben kann beobachtet werden
konnten allerdings musste die er den
sogenannten oberflächenwellen enden
diese laufen langsamer als die raum
wellen und lassen die erde erzittern
hinzu kommt eine weitere beobachtung die
klar und deutlich gegen das auftreten
eines klassischen erdbebens spricht und
zwar handelt es sich bei dem
beobachteten wellen um monochrom a
tische wellen also mit einer festen
wellenlänge und das eben über die ganzen
20 minuten hinweg die das ereignis bei
der insel mayotte wohl anhielt
gewöhnliche erdbeben verursachen dagegen
während mit verschiedenen frequenzen ja
das alles passt laut der fachleute also
nicht wirklich zusammen was also steckt
hinter diesem phänomen dass geologie
institut büro der recherchen geologica
mini-wm aus frankreich hat sich dazu mit
einer vermutung geäussert demnach
könnten vulkanische aktivitäten in
kombination mit bewegungen der
erdplatten für die seismischen signale
verantwortlich sein und tatsächlich ist
die insel mayotte eine sehr alte
vulkaninsel also die insel selber ist
der pegel in der mitte eines kraters und
in deren umfeld bereits seit mai 2018
einige seismische vorfälle registriert
werden konnten entsteht dort also ein
neuer weg haben laut den französischen
experten haben in dieser region seit dem
erdbeben schwärme stattgefunden also
hunderte kleinere erschütterungen und
zudem auch einige wenige starke beben
das letzte ende november und zwar mit
einer stärke von 5,1
dennoch sei das alles wohl nicht allein
durch tektonische effekte also durch
bewegungen der erdplatten zu erklären
die wahrscheinlichkeit ist laut des
französischen forschungsteams hoch
das sich wohl vor der küste ein neues
mathematisches zentrum bildet und magma
aufsteigt also es könnte einen vulkan
bald geben denn dies würde die
schwarmbeben gut erklären ein weiteres
indiz für diese erklärung ist auch die
tatsache dass sich die insel mayotte
verlagert seit dem sommer 2018 nämlich
sechs zentimeter in östliche und 3 cm in
südliche richtung das zeigen gps-daten
im geologischen maßstab ist das relativ
schnell das große probleme an der sache
die region ist geologisch gesehen kaum
erforscht und niemand kann vorhersagen
was als nächstes passiert möglich wäre
beispielsweise ein sehr schweres beben
oder auch das heranwachsen eben eines
neuen vulkans vor ort wir bleiben an
diesen mysteriösen erdbewegungen auf
jeden fall dran eine andere frage
die äußerst spannend ist kann eine super
intelligenz aus einem computer
ausbrechen dafür hier klicken
die neugier zone beschäftigt sich mit
diesem extrem spannenden thema den kanal
müsst ihr unbedingt abonnieren richtig
krass hier geht es direkt zum kanal und
vergesst die glocken natürlich nicht
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran